stop stop stop you're going to take
someone we watched you grow up as
Hermione Granger and Emma Watson we're
pretty sure you're the muggle version of
your character
we know you turned in a whole essay
about your character to your director
for the fourth movie and now your
humanitarian and activist is the belief
that men and women should have equal
rights it's exactly the type of
character Hermione would have pursued
but instead of fighting for the rights
of house elves you are fighting for the
rights of women all around the world
it's been eight years since Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Part 2 was
released let's catch up on the cast and
find out their current ages and
relationships Emma Watson Emma Watson is
only 29 years old and she has already
accomplished so much she has acted in
several movies after Harry Potter but
that's not all she's done she got a
degree from Brown University
she is a UN goodwill ambassador for
women's and girls rights she keeps her
love life under wraps but her last known
boyfriend was Cleese Chord Overstreet
the two split in 2018 Rupert Grint who
doesn't love Ron Weasley Rupert Grint is
now 31 years old
lately most of his acting has been in
British and American TV shows including
sick note and snatch Rupert is great at
keeping his personal life out of the
press and that's because his life is
pretty much drama-free he has been
dating actress Georgia groom since 2011
Bonnie writes the fiery Gryffindor Ginny
Weasley was played by Bonnie right she
is currently 28 years old she's
continued doing some acting and has also
been a model she has her own production
company called bonbon Lumiere
Bonnie's most recent relationship was
with Simon Hammerstein but no one has
confirmed if they're still together
Shawn bigger saw Shawn play the
Gryffindor Quidditch captain Oliver wood
in the first two Harry Potter movies the
chasers handle the Quaffle and tried to
put it through one of those three hoops
only to reprise his role in the last
film he is now 36 years old he has
continued acting on-screen
stage he also had a band for a while
there is no reliable information about
his relationship status Harry Melling he
might have played the mean Dudley
Dursley but Harry Melling is a really
nice guy he is 30 years old he recently
acted in The Ballad of Buster Scruggs
in 2018 and got rave reviews there's no
information about him dating anyone
so Harry is probably single at the
moment davon Murray CMAs Finnegan was
played by Devin Murray the 31 year old
has only had one small acting role since
the Harry Potter films Devin got into
some financial and legal trouble when he
was younger but he's doing great now he
spends most of his time working with
horses
there's no news about any love interests
Robert Pattinson before he was Edward
and Twilight Robert played Cedric
Diggory in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire
Robert is 33 years old in 2021 he will
be playing Batman Robert has been dating
model Suki Waterhouse for the last year
but he keeps details about their
relationship to himself
Alfred Enoch Alfred a NOC is 30 years
old and he's had a lot of success since
his Gryffindor days he was on the series
how to get away with murder for four
years he has been dating American
actress
Audino me King since 2017 Stanislav yeah
Nowitzki Viktor Krum silver my knees
heart and Goblet of Fire these days
stanislav is doing a little acting in
various european productions he is
really active on Instagram and travels a
lot Sana's father four years old he also
appears to be single clemens Poissy the
other Triwizard champion was Fleur
Delacour play by Clemens Poissy Clemens
is 36 years old she starred in a British
French crime drama TV series for several
years and is still acting on TV shows
she is currently single but she has a
son from her relationship with Emmerich
Glacies
Evanna Lynch Luna Lovegood is a fan
favorite I can see them too
you're just as sane as I am Ivana is
currently 28 years old she's continued
acting some and was on Dancing with the
Stars she is an animal rights activist
and has a podcast about veganism which
she hosts with her ex and former co-star
Robbie Jarvis
he played James Potter in the flashbacks
James and Oliver Phelps the Weasley
twins are just as close in real life as
their characters they have both done a
little acting since the series ended and
they travel a lot for Harry Potter
events
Oliver is married to a woman named Katie
humpin James was last known to be dating
Annika austell the twins are 33 years
old Matthew Lewis Neville Longbottom
grew up to be a Wizarding hero and
Matthew Lewis is doing pretty well too
now 30
Maddie's has stayed pretty busy with
acting he got married to Angela Jones in
2018 she was a Universal Studios
employee that he met at the Wizarding
World theme park isn't that the most
magical love story ever tom Felton Draco
Malfoy may have been one cunning
Slytherin but tom Felton is a pretty
nice guy luckily above the age of six
people we usually realize that I'm not
that much of a target he has continued
acting he was in the series the flash
and the YouTube original origin he also
writes songs and performs them on his
Instagram tom is 32 years old and
appears to be single at the moment
Daniel Radcliffe the star of Harry
Potter movies is now 30 years old he has
continued acting both on Broadway and in
Hollywood earlier this year Daniels
starred as an employee on the show
miracle workers he has several more
upcoming projects
he is currently dating Aaron dark they
met in 2013 when they filmed kill your
darlings together who is your favorite
Hogwarts student let us know in the
comments be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe thanks for watching we'll see
you next time
on the thing
[Music]